[Applause]
my name is Adam revolve this is my wife
Danielle revolve we're from California
we met in September of 2013 got married
in October 2014 combined our household
and we were about $100,000 in debt I
heard about Dave Ramsey from my
brother-in-law and a friend and a couple
different people I came to him and told
him all about it he jumped on board
pretty quick I got tired of the phone
calls from collectors and it was getting
old I was very excited to listen to
proposal about budgeting and getting
everything set up
[Music]
we are the floor-by-floor family we are
one month into our three-month road trip
so right now our map is based off of
where we know people wherever we want to
go between is tentative and flexible and
we'll see where the road takes us we
know we're doing something out of the
ordinary because every time we tell
people they're like oh my gosh it's so
awesome we wish we could do it yeah I've
had a couple people say so how did you
just pick up everything and leave well I
was blessed with a job I can do on the
road and we can live off of that income
while we travel it's enough to pay for
gas and food and retirement and still do
all that stuff he can get the chance to
stay with Sierra which she didn't gonna
do in there back home being able to
travel the entire summer and have a plan
for when we're done certainly not in the
moon living like no one else for us is
hiring choices having options we don't
have to answer to somebody else or be
slaves in a sense to somebody else we
can do what we're interested in what we
want to do we have choices but still
being smart about it and not we're just
gonna live till the money runs out
that's not what we're doing we're being
smart with what we have and we would
rather do something big than have a
house so I know the American dream is to
have a house and we were like
you don't need our house we don't really
like Southern California we got rid of
our consumer debts so we lived that free
with just our mortgage for almost a year
but we wanted something even more than
that and so we figured why not make a
big leap everything lined up because we
had a vision we had some control over it
we had made wise choices we know how to
say no after we sold the house we were
able to buy the motor home for cash so
it's not just all aligned well because
we were following Dave Ramsey's
principles and set ourselves
for me when people ask oh why are you
doing this my answer is kind of why not
[Music]
from the planner analyzer perspective I
know that I have we have a good cushion
the catch us if we fall and we didn't
actually read the 4-hour workweek by Tim
Ferriss and he kind of said imagine
worst-case scenario of what you're doing
and would you be able to come back from
that and I'm like yeah the worst-case
scenario the chances of that happening
based off of who we are and how we live
is pretty slim so high because we didn't
just jump we planned for probably six
months to a year and it's fun because
our plan is yeah we probably want to
settle near Carson City Reno but hey if
we find somewhere else we like along the
way we might just stop like in you ray
there was an opening for a full-time
chocolatier it said you don't need any
experience we'll train you or just
looking for the right personality like
we could've done that if we wanted to we
could uproot and move to you ray and I
could be a chocolatier he can work for a
Jeep company like we have that option or
we can move to Carson City so down buy a
house start our own business
work for company out there that was my
thing we're doing what's best for our
family the three of us this is what's
best for us it's a good opportunity for
Sierra to have exposure to try to make
her not a slave to structure like I can
be and to give her this time with us
this undivided time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you